bien alors on va passer à des choses
plus sérieuses a review on ne bouge pas
lundi nyan
vous avez bougé oui oui j'ai vu mon
chien bon j'ai pas réalisé vous avez les
petits martinez tout à l'heure ils sont
destinés à dalian et je les cherche à
petit martin eu à la fin bien alors j'ai
près je peux bouger là avait brillé vous
pensez à quoi en ce moment une chatte
moralité
franchement que je ne dois pas oublié
d'annoncer l'émission de vivement
dimanche prochain de demain avec bernard
henri lévy ah oui c'est dramatique on
l'a on me l'avait demandé avant de venir
voilà je me dis que quand je vais
pouvoir le placer ouais c'est fait moi
c'est bien comme ça en moins nous on
sait qu'on peut oublier n'a pas fallu
bien quand vous vous regardez dans le
miroir le matin vous vous dites quoi
trop tard pour la moumoute je me dis non
je me dis qu'elle quelle chance il à ce
miroir ou voir refléter une image aussi
sympathique vous auriez vers semblait
acquis quand vous étiez petit orlando
petit moi j'ai essayé mais moi les
bronches isama dessus et les cheveux
comme ça vous auriez aimé ressembler à
un clic vous étiez petit petit j'aurais
voulu être zorro ou d'artagnan mais me
connaissant j'aurais mis le costume de
d'artagnan pour aller faire euros ouais
sergent garcia avec la compétition et
pas mariés arrivés non quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois début
septembre tout pour une histoire tout à
fait privé mais bon voilà monfils qui a
18 ans et demi parts et le papa et en
angleterre pour un an
ils ont étudié la musique et l'anglais
et le moment de la séparation ça a été
très émouvant mais on était tous en ont
marre et les tours non le 2 septembre je
pleurais pas encore pour les tours de
chant ce film là bas ce sens de la
prémisse
désolé monsieur me documentant à
l'annoncé si la cia vous avez écouté
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi j'achèterai plutôt dans
le temps une caméra vidéo pour filmer
mes enfants petit parce que c'est pas de
documents et ils ont horriblement changé
oui oui oui bon moment non je veux dire
ces règlements sont magnifiques mais
réaliste d'attendre et à autre chose ah
c'est vrai je me le dit souvent encore
là tout à l'heure la d où je dis les
taureaux vraiment yann l'animal highway
pragmatique et à nez rouge couilles le
taux des grosses grosses couilles votre
chat oui vous savez ça mais vous savez
pourquoi
enfin non un dessinateur ouais qu'est ce
qui fait quand il doit quand il doit
dessiner quelque chose d'humain par
exemple on regarde ça mène
qu'est ce qui vous a fait le plus mal
retourne dans ton pays ah oui et on m'a
dit ça à bruxelles ce n'est pas si ou
aller la dernière chose que vous faites
avant de vous coucher
non alors avant de me coucher je je
reste quelques minutes debout ou assis
amont pour quoi faire
c'est vraiment le taureau ça est très
maladroit à la fois t'as pas une +25
alternative avant de se coucher et et ou
debout à 6 1
l'image
quand même que je mets la vie la
dernière personne que vous ayez envie de
tuer fait le type moi c'est les gens
vous savez les gens qui vous tiennent
pas la porte ouverte quand vous les
suivez
ouais ce sont les gens qui haïssent et
laird en bagnole quand vous voulez
traverser un peu de poids sinon tu un
psychopathe quoi en fait je sens que je
suis tout le monde en fait t'as tout le
monde figurent qu'est ce que vous avez
déjà pensé au suicide
oui quand mon premier livre s'achève sur
un dessin du chat qui dit si le type qui
me dessine mort un jour je me suicide
si on veut se suicider c'est mieux de le
faire le matin plutôt que le soir ça
fait une journée de boulot en moins
comment vous vivez avec le chat c'est à
dire vous vous dites
yagg et luc eia le chalut maginez vous
vous dites ça c'est pour le chat le chat
penserait ça ou vous êtes le chat non
pas du tout je suis un très bon orlando
900 très mauvais est-ce que vous avez
menti vendre cette interview là où oui
une fois
ah bon quand je vous dis oui une fois
que j'ai menti beaucoup plus souvent
voilà philippiques l'incarnent le chat
le dernier album
ces deux éditions casterman